now the prime minister of the solomon
islands has survived a no-confidence
vote in parliament it follows last
week's riots when crowds burned down
dozens of buildings and looted shops in
the capital onyara at least three people
were killed in the unrest my lungs
simmering regional rivalries economic
problems and accusations of china's
influence over the government troops
from australia new zealand and other
neighboring nations have been deployed
the prime minister defended his
government's actions shortly before the
vote
i did not allow myself to succumb
to the dictates
of hooligans
and lawlessness
i want to thank the participating
countries intervention forces
who are on the ground
mr speaker to help return normalcy
in our country
on behalf of the people and government
express our sincere
thanks
sarah clark is covering the story for us
from brisbane in australia so he
survived the vote how politically secure
is he now
well he was almost always going to
survive this particular vote of no
confidence simply because his party has
the majority but when it came down to
the actual numbers uh 15 mps backed the
motion of no confidence and 32 uh
rejected it and to abstain but he
survived votes of no confidence in the
past but he has actually been defeated
twice but the difference between those
when he was defeated and now is simply
because his party has the majority but
it was a lengthy and often heated uh
debate uh in the parliament in honiara
on monday the opposition leader matthew
whale he was what he he led this
particular campaign to deceit the prime
minister his key accusation was that the
provinces have lost trust
in the prime minister and his erratic
poor and mercenary decision-making made
it difficult for a country that was
already struggling the member for
malayta which is the province the most
populous province he also made some key
accusations and is also driving this
campaign to force the prime minister to
stand down he said that the solemn
islands is paralyzed and can't afford
another round of instability but the
prime minister he made an emotional
often fiery defense calling some of his
critics
thugs and hooligans but as i mentioned
he survived yet another motion of no
confidence and will continue his
government will continue
leading the country what does this mean
for concern about continued street
unrest though
well certainly there was some uh concern
that uh on monday with this vote of no
confidence being debated in parliament
that there could be some uh unrest in
the aftermath no matter which way it
went that we had businesses i was shut
down or closed early we had a huge and
heavy police presence across honiara and
also as you mentioned earlier we've got
the peacekeepers who've been
enforced over the last couple of weeks
since those four days of civil unrest
where we saw i had three people died as
a result those peacekeepers are there
but these are long-running grievances
between the state i mentioned the
province the malaysian province uh and
the central government accusations of
neglect that infrastructure had not been
would have been abandoned and economic
funds had been frozen and these these
particular accusations are not going to
go away and there's also the criticism
of the solomon islands ditching its
partnership with taiwan in favor of
china but as i mentioned that the prime
minister has denied all these
allegations he said the country is in in
goods a good
position at the moment he's also denied
allegations of corruption uh but we
spoke to an analyst who looks at the
pacific and he pretty much said that he
doesn't believe or there could
there could be some unrest in the near
future but definitely down the track
these grievances will continue uh to be
a problem in the solomon islands
all right thanks so much
sarah clark there